[Music]
Jimmy Kimmel apologizes for his jabs at
Sean Hannity into the LGBTQ community
now I have to say something about it
after days of bickering Kimmel attempts
to end his feud with the Fox News host
on Sunday Kimmel released a statement on
Twitter writing in part quote while I
admit I did have fun with our
back-and-forth after some thought I
realized that the level of vitriol from
all sides mine and me included does
nothing good for anyone and in fact is
harmful to our country about this it
first started with Hannity took offense
to Kimmel poking fun at First Lady
Melania Trump's accent poor little Jimmy
he can't stomach the fact that we dared
to call him out for smearing the First
Lady Melania Trump when he was mocking
her accent as she was reading to little
children
Kimmel eventually received death threats
toward his family and many in the LGBTQ
community took offense to this response
during a Twitter war with Hannity after
the Fox commentator referred to Kimmel
as Harvey Weinstein jr. quote don't
worry just keep tweeting you'll get back
on top or destructor fur you on bottom
Kimmel apologized writing by lampooning
Sean Hannity's deference to the
president I most certainly did not
intend to belittle or upset members of
the gay community and to those who took
offense I apologized Kennedy has since
responded to Kimmel's lengthy message
stating he plans to issue a full and
comprehensive response on his show
Monday
[Music]